okay you have Rook D1 oh
that was sick oh my God that was nasty
oh what a mate that he weaved
in their 2018 World Chess Championship
Match Magnus Carlson took an early draw
against Fabiano caruana in a favorable
position in the final game famously
indicating a strong belief in his
chances in tie breaks and speed chests
against Carolina four years later
Fabiano caruana has made big strides in
his speed chest and has eradicated the
myth that he is not good at it would he
be able to hold us on today against the
goat though
in game one both players got big past
pawns would Carolina's d-pawn or
Carlson's epon be the better Pawn Rook
C1 the Expo 93 okay he finds it 982
check and then the king escapes the pin
so that's not possible Fabi brings his
King up
oh Rook D7 oh that's a knife that's a
knife right there take D2
he's gonna pick up the pawns and it's
falling apart for fobby totally winning
now but only four seconds this is
blunderable man this is wonderful 100
Knight takes that five tries to capture
no but just take an E7 yeah this is over
here comes the queen yeah oh man you got
problems here you got problems here
unreal what a what a game one in the
next game Carlson showed a winning
recipe that he would try to deploy many
times in the match one get a small Edge
and two just keep pressing utilizing
each move and each second on the clock
to create problems and eventually crack
resilient defense from Carolina oh my
gosh
he's just gonna push it oh yeah
that's it magnify
Magnus doing what he does
better than anybody in the world which
is convert on these small advantages
Carolina defended a pawn down position
in game three ultimately holding a draw
with only Kings remaining in game four
it was Carlson's turn to defend three
pawns down he's down three pawns and I
think it's gonna be a draw amazingly
game five also reached a draw with only
Kings remaining that was three games in
a row that were played to the very end
game six though was never destined for
peace as the players reached an end game
with racing Rook Pawns in mutual time
trouble White had just a little bit of
an opportunity there but again if Bobby
misses this one he'll be shaking his
head as we head to the next game get
ready for it because Abby looking for a
way to get his Knight around now he's
worse again and Magnus might promote his
pawn bishop D5 what a move now Magnus
back in the driver's seat make a move
Magnus we gotta move one second one
second God oh my God oh my God oh my God
Magnus is winning he's gonna go Knight
C3 knock the bishop away oh my God Bobby
played F5 in panic he had nothing else
to do and it's over Carlson put on an
absolute clinic in the seventh game
smoothly converting a positional Edge
and to draw in game eight into the five
plus one time control with Carlson
leading six to two with four wins and
four draws when would Carolina get his
first win
Carlson opened the three plus one time
control with a queen SEC and Magnus goes
for it but Bobby responded well and he
was better according to the engine
Carlson had a fortress but his time
trouble set in the game took on an eerie
resemblance to his famous game six win
from the world championship match
against Yan yapomnishi what is going on
five seconds four seconds
Carlson is definitely the one playing
for a win here I agree even the time
scrambled you go C5 there's Queen G1
though picking up the pun Here Comes G5
he just gives up the pawn oh King D7
it's gonna be over this is just like
Carlson nepo and he's just pre-moving
wait it's back to maybe a Perpetual
check no no there's no way you can no
way
no more checks that's it and the Knight
next to the king putting on putting on a
clinic a chaotic draw in the second
three plus one game preceded possibly
the finest in-game ever played in the
speed Chess Championship if it gets any
way in Black Will Be black will be
losing if this bishop can somehow get it
oh we're not just being picking up
anyway
the idea is HG Bishop takes G5 holy
smoked my brain is exploding
fgf6 and the one promotes God
God and Bishop takes cheap flights I
can't believe it you have to play bishop
d8 and then H6 breaking through again
and suddenly White's got plenty of
winning chances and you could play H6 at
your leisure can Fabi build some sort of
Fortress or King G7 E4 King G6 and Fabi
can move his king that's big because oh
the bishop Bundy for the pawn promotes
it might be a drop huge move think he's
holding it I mean Carlson's gonna try to
get his King back to F4 I think
yep now the E4 opponent has gone too far
um okay it should be a draw objectively
but I think Magnus is gonna pull through
I think C5 King C5
it's it's over the King goes to D5 you
push to C6 and you force the bishop
trade it's a winning king of one ending
close
this might have been the most
unbelievable game of the match Danny
seriously this has to be studied by
everybody who wants to learn something
about Chess after the match a
stabilizing drop preceded another clean
Pawn up conversion for Carlson and while
the next game Saw Carolina get a big
Edge early Carlson still turned things
around and he picked up another in-game
point before chaos ensued in the next
time scramble he's got two seconds
though Magnus you gotta move quickly you
might lose on time trying to mate him
he's weaving his tentacles around
Black's King Bishop G5 and if five
there's F3 and G4 and it's over three
and G4 Bishop G5 it has to give up the
exchange and so oh my God and he might
still get mated on e4
oh
my God that was nasty
oh what a mate that he weaved how often
does a king get checkmated in the middle
of the board on F4 a big smile from
Carlson at the end there showed that
even he was enjoying just how good his
chest was today what form Carolina got
his chance in the final Blitz game as
Carlson played a spectacular Sack or
even A6 should be considered to disrupt
the pawn on B5 whoa
Carlson we were expecting what is he
doing oh my God look at this 23 is made
but it can't take because Queen E3 and
then Rook f8 after King F5
it's a great practical attempt Bishop B5
comes to mind he's down a rook I know
he's down the exchange okay dear Lord
holy smokes too many pawns for the
exchange
Magnus is gonna no he just takes D3 even
more direct Queen F3 check at minimum
it's over rookie five Rook F1 mates
mates what a fork
it's not even fair you can't even lose
the pawn because work up one would have
been mate
this is just absurd thirteen three
Carlson led by 10 and had not lost a
game could he deliver an undefeated
speed Chess Championship victory
Carlson opened the bullet time control
with a convincing win in the first game
but game two was even more impressive as
he decided things in just 19 moves by
trapping Carolina's Bishop do you think
it would be an exaggeration and I'm I'm
I don't mean to beat a dead horse here
you know we pointed out many many times
how great Carlson is played I don't want
to keep repeating myself but do you
think it's fair to call this one of the
greatest match performances of all time
the third game was an absolute mess the
eval bar was swinging all over the place
as Carlson was forced to sack a piece oh
my God now the eval bar is swinging
is running
we're swinging now we got our blunders
oh H4 is falling in the end we need not
quite not quite
how is Carlson doing this he's still
alive he's pushing the h-bond and he's
winning after Queen he's alive
Rook up seven ended the game but now
fobby's turned it back around a little
bit not quite I think Queen G8 ends it
oh Mike no he can take with the Dozen
Rook H6 95 okay look out for Queen C6
and discover checks no the eight look
out for Rook takes C6 was the threat one
second now Queen takes a chain
I'm freaking tired of this my heart was
pounding too ladies and gentlemen I am
beyond words speech Beyond everything
right now a beautiful shot closed out
bullet game number four we enough Knight
G4 check first even oh my gosh Magnus
does it again the fifth game was another
Carlson clinic as he stole upon stole
all of the squares and won convincingly
but the sixth bullet game had an even
bigger wow factor in which the final
position perfectly conveyed the level of
domination that Carlson had been
displaying all match long
Isis
that was now 10 consecutive wins for
Carlson and he was not done yet as he
racked up an 11th win in the next game
Carolina finally got chances to press in
an end game in the following one yeah
he's gonna take D5 this way
just be careful don't blunder The Rook
on A1
I think
he should have traded Queens he's gonna
lose the pawn now Danny he has Queen D7
oh
but then I guess
yeah Rook C7 oh my land she's holding
nobody
he freezes the king though this is just
the theoretical draw oh my gosh progress
dude the presence of mine from Magnus
there I swear he plays these end games
like he has the table base memorized
with time dwindling Carlson found
chances and tactics in the next in-game
position Focus A2 Bishop sorry I missed
Bishop C3 to A1 block kid okay
oh my God he does it again
okay Bobby has one more game one
opportunity mom spaghetti Carlson smiled
showed he knew exactly what the score
was and with 50 seconds left he needed
only not to lose the next game with
black to secure the most dominant speed
Chess Championship Match victory in
history
Carolina was not out to make things easy
though as he picked upon oh Rook a two
and the king is cut off again yeah he's
holding the king in in a in a cage it's
the 66 you can even display King F6 or
Rook D2
yeah or Rook D2
yeah it's a drop it's official folks
just hold it F6
I don't know about D6 but that does even
so The Rook can't afford to go for the
H1 because the a pawn will Queen so okay
that does let the king out oh Bobby
doesn't take it oh because they'll be
checked by The Rook
so I think we have yeah it's official
repetition that's happened everyone we
have made history here
oh
oh my God
22-4 undefeated an absolutely amazing
and unprecedented performance from the
goat Magnus Carlsen only Hikaru Nakamura
has also had an undefeated SEC Victory
his match against hoe fawn
Carlson advances to the speed Chess
Championship semi-finals where he will
play the winner of Wesley so vs Maxine
vashayla Groth a match against mvl would
give him a sweet chance for revenge for
his 2020 speed Chess Championship defeat
in the interview Carlson was ebullient
and open with his thoughts about the
match there were some positions that I
wasted where I was winning but generally
thought we don't lose you you don't uh
I have quite a lot
[Music]